This method can be
expressed pretty directly in terms of Boolean circuits.
One way to think about it is to start off with a small circuit for adding two single bit integers together.
That'll give us a number
between zero and two, where the lesser significant bit is the XOR of the input bits
and the more significant bit, or the carry bit if you prefer, is the AND of the two input bits.
Sometimes we refer to a circuit that performs these
two operations together as a half adder.
That works fine when there
are just two input bits, but if we want to add together integers with more than just one bit each,
we're going to need to deal
with the carry bits somehow.
So what we can do is to cascade
two half adders together and take the OR of the
carry bits they produce to create what's called a full adder,
which is basically a Boolean circuit for adding three single
bit numbers together.
And once we have a full adder, we can add numbers together
simply by cascading, proceeding from the least significant bit
to the most significant bit. We're basically just implementing the standard addition algorithm using the full adders to
deal with the carry bits.
So what's the cost of this computation?
Well, we need seven elementary
gates for each XOR gate, which means 10 gates for a half adder
and therefore 21 gates for a full adder, which is two half adders plus an OR gate.
So at the end of the day, if our input numbers both have AND bits, we need a half adder for
the least significant bit
and a full adder for every other bit, and the end result is 21 times N minus one plus 10 or 21 N minus 11 gates in total.
If we decided for some reason that we didn't want to
count the FANOUT gates and we included the XOR
gates in our gate set, we'd need five N minus
three gates in total.
It's nice to know exactly how many gates or elementary operations are required to perform different computations,
such as we just saw with integer addition.
And of course, if we actually want to implement these computations, we need to know these details.
But if we always go into this much detail, especially for more
complicated algorithms, we'll be very quickly buried in details
that in many cases have
secondary importance.
One way to simplify matters that's very common in the
analysis of algorithms is to make use of big-O notation,
which allows us to express
and compare rates of growth in a pretty simple way
that's very convenient.
And here you can see the definition that underlies this notation.
Suppose that we have
two functions G and H, which we can think of as taking non-negative integer
values for simplicity,
although that's not actually required. Maybe G and H represent costs of different computations, for instance.
We then say that G is big-O of H, which is traditionally written
with an equal sign like this.
If G of N is at most some
positive constant C times H of N, so long as N is large enough.
So this is about what
happens when N gets large.
Formally, what large enough means is that there's some choice of N zero so that the inequality is true
whenever N is at least N zero.
The key here is that these
numbers C and N zero are fixed.
They can be any numbers at
all, but whatever they are, they can't change as N grows.
If you've never seen this
kind of definition before, it might take some getting used to and you can find resources
that will explain this concept
in a lot more detail than
I'm able to in this lesson.
Usually what we do is to choose
the function H to be simple in order to express something about how quickly the function G grows.
For example, the function whose value is 17 times N cubed minus 257
times N squared plus
65,537 is big-O of N cubed, and you can fit this
example to the definition
by picking C and N zero appropriately.
For example, if we take C to be 18, then we'll have that
the expression is indeed at most 18 times N cubed
as long as N is big enough.
Tying this notation back to the
example of integer addition, what we can now say is that there exists a family of Boolean circuits
for adding non-negative integers together such that the size of the N circuit, meaning the one that works
for inputs of length N
is big-O of N. The actual size of CN
according to our analysis was 21 times N minus 11,
but that's big-O of N.
Now it's not always a smart thing to do to throw away details like this, but here it makes sense
because it reveals the essential nature of the standard addition algorithm, which is that its cost scales linearly
in the size of the numbers
that we're adding together, and this expression is not sensitive to some of the low level
details of our model,
such as precisely which gates we consider to be elementary operations.
For instance, if we decided that XOR gates should be considered as
elementary operations or that FANOUT gates shouldn't
count as gates or both,
we'd still have that integer addition can be computed at cost big-O of N.